depuis le 15 janvier on assiste à des
mouvements sociaux de plus en plus
important sur l'ensemble du pays
et puis depuis cinq jours à des
violences nocturnes dans les banlieues
défavorisées de la capitale et puis dans
d'autres vies sur l'ensemble du
territoire
taterka cieux entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre qui n'hésite pas à
user de bombes lacrymogènes pour essayer
de disperser ces populations on assiste
à la dégradation de biens publics ont à
sa dégradation de bâtiments
administratifs ou encore des pillages de
magasins beaucoup d'arrestations on a
comptabilisé plus de six ans selon le
ministère de l'intérieur des jeunes
populations entre 14 et 25 ans ces
jeunes là qui était il ya dix ans lors
de la révolution ont encore des enfants
que vous dire que c'est plus et les
jeunes populations qui sont dans la rue
aujourd'hui et qui affrontent la police
est jeune qu'on dit il issu du système
poste à l'évolution le forum économique
et social est tunisien a mis en place
une plateforme composée notamment à des
avocats pour venir en aide et soutenir
assez soutenir ces jeunes qui ont été
arrêtés par la police
on n'est pas dans une logique de
contestation au classique quand on a pu
le voir pendant les premières heures et
les premiers jours de la révolution il y
a dix ans les revendications ne sont pas
encore claires mais ce qu'on peut savoir
c'est que ce confinement ce premier jour
de confinement qui coïncidait avec la
célébration des 10 ans de la révolution
en tunisie a mis de l'huile sur le feu
dans un contexte économique assez tendue
en tunisie où le chômage des jeunes
représente qu'un pour cent et atteint
même 30 % dans certaines nous on refuse
du pays beaucoup de manifestations en
journée avec des slogans hostiles au
gouvernement elle aussi hostile au parti
politique islamiste ennahda d'être à la
base de ce fonctionnement en tunisie qui
est complètement chaotique d'un point de
vue crise économique
cette jeunesse-là compte bien rester
dans la rue ils ont choisi la voie de la
violence comme ils l'ont expliqué car
c'est un moyen pour eux de susciter le
débat notamment dans la classe politique
mais aussi dans les médias sur la
situation aux élus les tunisiens
actuellement et surtout depuis dix ans
il ya eu certains acquis avec la
révolution notamment à la liberté
d'expression mais concernant le
quotidien concernant l'aspect économique
et rien n'a changé voir les choses se
sont empirées une situation qui devient
pénible et insupportable
leur point tunisien et on doit
s'attendre en corse est liée à de vives
tensions entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre